[Music]
in spoiled brat news submitted by Yeti
love the JK crew thank you
he is like a bomb in a snowman a rich
girl was charged with shooting her
father after he depicted her what looked
to the father
Janani all this because if he died you
said he died I think he lives - that's
why he's charging her yep hmm no he died
oh sure do so now where's she gonna live
that stupid it's his house you kill him
you're not gonna have a house no more
and you don't have a place to live
either how did this father go wrong
though how old is she
30-100 oldest [ __ ] [ __ ] and you still
live it what your daddy
yep stupid Britney Simpson Wow Let Me In
Britney she looks like Oh cheap what
does she do like [ __ ] don't smoke
language I mean a sunbathing with what I
prolly what the [ __ ] what is your
lifeguard like what the [ __ ] what kind
of sunglasses go perfectly above the
eyebrow and go all about that blonde
steadiness oh you can't be it yeah
spends a lot of time in the Sun that's
for sure I mean after she killed her
daddy she went to go back to the beach
like what the [ __ ] oh they live in a
million-dollar waterfront mansion
bourbon near Charleston South Carolina
her dad really good property then yeah
her dad uh was a film industry workers
stainless Robert Simpson 66 years old
goodbye a waterfront mansion in LA for a
million dollars ah dude a million dollar
home in that area must be [ __ ] insane
[Laughter]
say Waterford property yeah
oh here's Robert by the way but South
Carolina beaches don't look like ours
yeah it looks like it what alligators I
like that dog that dogs awesome it looks
like an old Englishman so I don't know
what happened exactly for them to want
to kick out their daughter but a parity
one that's all you got enough reasoning
in how the [ __ ] are you 31 and you look
like that my god if you wake up everyday
and just punch yourself in the [ __ ]
face Jesus and so for some reason
they're keeping her out I am assuming
she didn't want to leave because the
parents had to go and get an eviction
order oh my god yes yes
death evict their own daughter yeah and
so they won that eviction order and so
no I'm not saving like what goes through
the mind of a 31 year old who has
absolutely no shame instinct like if my
parents started saying hey maybe it's
about time nope don't don't even
complete that sentence I know what
you're saying let me get out of here I
don't think anyone want any one of us in
this room would even allow for our
parents to even have the thought of like
oh I think I got a kick might get out I
would say that too but you say no more
just get me an apartment right across
say [ __ ] more there's this three-bedroom
house that I've been looking at in
Malibu if your dad I just meant that out
for me I'll be glad to move let me know
please yeah so just give me the word and
I'll leave the parish she had been
unemployed recently Ruby we got so days
after the when the eviction order which
kind of odd to me because it's a
graceful living there to be one
direction order but anyways days after
well the entire family was sleeping she
fatally shot her father in the chest
with a nine millimeter Smith & Wesson
pistol and so what she did is like she
Lannister she shot her father and she
ran out to the dock and tossed the gun
and her bloody clothes into the water
and then she ran back inside and she
started yelling like someone someone
broke in someone broke in and she was
trying to blame it on an intruder and so
but security cameras caught her
assailant no there was no forced entry
anywhere yeah so they they were looking
at that event on a society with the name
of uncle apparently like around 6:00
a.m.
her younger sister Brooke called 9-1-1
hysterical she was like just crying
telling the operator like i don't know i
just woke up i heard a gunshot my dad is
screaming and is there's blood
everywhere I think he's been shot and
she just cries even more and then the
operator asked how many suspects were
involved and then Brooke says my sister
is insisting that someone came in the
house and then the operator says oh like
a burglary ma'am
and she says I don't know I can smell
gunshot powder and then she asked okay
where are the suspects now she says I
don't know I don't know Britney come
here and Britt come here someone just
came in the house and then we figure
Britney in the back saying someone just
came in the back door someone just came
in and then uh apparently Brooke tells
the operator that she's saying that she
was downstairs
oh my god please hurry in an opera
as like are you or anyone else in
immediate danger Brooke says I don't
know and it's just like a lot it was
like hysterical 9-1-1 calls nonsense
so then cops arrived and then they start
talking to the neighbors neighbors
claimed that they saw a woman run to the
end of the dock and back just before
police arrived not in the woman's a
loving son even see that they went
what's going on here we got the windows
and stuff problem that probably matters
in both shots I'll probably do that too
probably in that neighborhood - it's
probably hella quiet nothing ever goes
on exactly yeah so then divers went in
to the lake they found a weapon and they
found a green book bag stuffed with a
pink t-shirt and Nike shorts which
recording support papers are saying that
that's exactly what Britney has been
wearing earlier that morning and they
caught her in surveillance footage from
the neighbors camera security camera so
they saw her wearing the exact same
clothes yeah be extra smart if you want
to commit a crime in a nice area
why did she kill with the dead
apparently likes snaps she's entitled
in fiction order yeah that's that was
her fling well that's what they reported
oh you know oh you had to do was
probably just work at a McDonald's
somewhere and then your daddy probably
would have got you a small little house
for you to live in but you didn't do it
because I know a couple of people
handful of people that I know that their
parents are so [ __ ] well-off and
literally told them you can work
anywhere it doesn't [ __ ] matter just
do something and then I'll provide the
rest and I feel like that's probably her
situation
oh sorry lucky baby that makes me [ __ ]
you know what interesting though with
people in that situation this is a
specific person I know this person was
telling me that you would think that's
very lucky but it's hard because when
you're given everything and you want to
be an ambitious person you don't know
what what to do because there's no
struggle because there's nothing to
fight for
exactly so that what they got to do is
let me prints in the popper style switch
put on the wig I'll be them I'll live
the life they give it to me they don't
know and when your parents say you could
literally work into McDonald's like why
why do you even care like it doesn't
matter so it's the parents fault because
what they really need to do is say right
on go away
do it yeah 100% [ __ ] right now eat
fine find your own way to eat daddy's
not going to give you a damn thing
that's what they need to do she looks
really bad now I didn't get over the
fact that she's 31 I also can't believe
that the parents got eviction order
because my eviction order would just be
my hand on their neck I get the [ __ ] out
of the house like a question raccoon hmm
a reverse raccoon so now you're in jail
yeah so [ __ ] I don't know do it I would
love him if if I do have money it's like
what you said it's difficult because
like what is there to live for there's
no dream if you can have to dream
already without working for it I know
for the first five years though I'd be
pretty damn happy you know waking uh
relaxing yeah with some wind in your
hand I will get my dog back picture with
my dog all day for no [ __ ] reason
have some cucumbers on your eyes yeah oh
is it huh totally food in my dog's face
could be a pudding why would you this
would you stay here in LA I'll probably
live in the same place you know me I
don't be much I would just stay here and
I just travel out I don't really [ __ ]
care I love to be honest with you so
then if you guys have a lot of money and
you guys start a family and have kids or
you're gonna raise your kids like having
them know that you guys are rich oh yes
Truman Show
do you wanna be like the two inches up
to when they're 80 they're gonna find
out
other than that they're going there
[ __ ] dirt poor they're going to think
that there also have black for some
reason and Romanian access they're going
to be full Korean kids that think of a
classical opera I thought I was doing no
I'm just kidding
oh-ho like you know both of your hearing
you know the pigment of your skin color
mom and dad a little bit of because I'm
a black man now I'm saying no about my
kids be spoiled though I really hope I
don't think I keep on telling myself
that I'm not gonna get my kids [ __ ] but
I think that's a fun get in the last
there's a lot yeah I just I think you
can give your kids you just kind of
balance it out with hard work yeah I
can't wait to the day where I give it
[ __ ] and I get to take it away from them
looks so great [ __ ] love it dude like
oh you want to talk back honey you don't
have a bed anymore you [ __ ] sleep on
the [ __ ] floor you don't take away
their uh their luxuries you take away
the necessities oxygen water
oh nice for you bury them in the
backyard with cement and all the
necessities at once yeah I don't know
how you take away oxygen make them wear
that [ __ ] ninja snorkel mask oh my
god spot that manga [ __ ] in Hawaii
they're like Q this is the ultimate
premium one you wasn't [ __ ] back here
you breathe through anybody knows how
you stuck your mouth right to bed it
suffocates you what the [ __ ] man fix
your breathing yeah how I don't know
yeah and I don't know how to clear it
either so visually it's dope because
water doesn't get in you don't you could
see all like you know but the breathing
just sucks I mean I [ __ ] up because
when you have regular goggles right and
the mouthpiece you would just like take
it off when you're on top and then you
just kind of kick your legs and you put
it back on with this model is a whole
ordeal yeah so what was house drowning
all the time hey the water will go with
like that hard so I just had to close my
eyes and you started swimming for like
collar water because the water can only
tie bad but what I thought I was going
to make you like we're in luck I wasn't
and I saw the deep in the deep actually
like the meso I took his [ __ ] well Jay
can use phantoms I hope you guys liked
that video once again remember if you
want to be involved just submit some
article them I'll suck your dick no but
seriously though there's more videos up
there
[Music]